[Music]
they call me offensive controversial
it's only two genders boys and girls
they can't cancel my message cuz I'm the
biggest independent rapper in the whole
freaking world CL that I'm racist y
right I'm not ashamed because I'm white
if every Caucasian is a bigot I guess
every muslim's a terrorist every liberal
is right I don't want to talk to folks
who don't get it Go woke go broke no
hope it's pathetic pro-choice pronouns
Pro love you're Progressive but you
ain't pro gun no wonder protected where
the American flags at remember when
people would hang those they've been
taken down they all been replaced with
blms or a rainbow that's true that is a
weird thing that happened when I was a
kid many if not most people hung
American flags outside their homes and
in their cars and stuff like that and
you just don't see that
anymore it's rare to see an American
flag hanging I remember once in college
my roommate and I got an American flag
someone gave it to us and we hung it
outside our window and it was a scandal
on campus we were told it was offensive
to people and so that started I guess
around
0809 now that's a good point time let's
look at the stats I've got the facts my
money like lizel my pockets are fat